[Music]
in just jerk it news
just doing it everyone was submitted by
Thai cos so Cooney Hika is Barton Gio's
a college has encouraged its students to
masturbate in effort to prevent sexual
assault oh I see what they don't think
masturbation that's not the same they're
just gonna jack off and then they're
sexually assault somebody then jack off
again cuz no one rapist has ever been
like what I just had to mess right oh
yeah that's what I should have done
instead of raping her but no one ever
[ __ ] says that those are two separate
things you think so so the unanimous
thing here everyone agrees that this is
stupid
yeah yeah I don't think I don't think
masturbation is stupid no like this
solution it's not a solution
it might help though I don't think
people rape because they can't jack off
I think they rape because they they're
very small and they want power yeah yeah
it's about the power all right well it
could be multiple reasons to because I
mean you can also look at the situation
where at a dorm party or like you know
having a party or whatever and you're
making out with someone and then all of
a sudden they don't want to have sex
with you anymore and now you're just
sexually frustrated
that's your carpet moment you're calm
but see that person who's already
macking on somebody already Jax it offs
I don't think there's like a lack of
jacking on that's more like self-control
yeah because it's yeah cuz it's all
impulses like yeah if they're strong
enough to control their impulses and
just go jack off somewhere they're not
probably gonna rape anybody
anyways so they need to talk you're
right that dude yeah exactly yeah and
people need to tell them it's not okay
to rape at a party we're at all if you
don't want to steal just make money and
buy it and also too when you're at that
age from 18 to 21 Jackie laughs not
gonna do [ __ ] you have so much [ __ ]
testosterone at that age dude now you
could jack off 14 times a day unless you
trapped yourself in your your dorm room
yeah and now they have you know you porn
and oh that's right yeah so they could
just [ __ ] you have
you know they're the cool sex toys now
so they could [ __ ] know you know I'm
just I'm trying to defend the the kid
that does it so he they could just jerk
off like and they have all the great
porn and they're not ever leave so they
can't assault anybody
right no way you feel me brother right I
can tell that you use a flashlight
cuz when you what you were doing the
Jackie yeah you had this versus like
this so you're right you're right yeah
so my thing is the yeah can you only
masturbate with the flashlight now yeah
really
unless I'm like visiting my folks in
Arizona and well then I'll make a
Pringles pocket [ __ ] did you learn from
[Laughter]
there really good at making be back yeah
they're great engineers how do you make
it so you take a Pringles can and you
dump the chips obviously you don't well
and then you take a you know not trash
bags but like store bags you know oh no
no you stuff them in the Pringles thing
that's percussion cushioning oh yeah
Suika taggers yeah and then you would
need a well a latex glove okay goodbye
man all right eight like five bucks
whatever
and you need rubber bands okay and then
the main ingredient which kind of
formulates the vagina part or at least
the of the lips yeah
sponges you take the sponges and then
you actually put the the latex glove in
there and you fold them outside inside
out uh-huh it forms the the hole yeah
well within the sponges being the
support system decides yeah come on my
channel and then do a how-to on this I
would love to yeah that's dub it's like
a DIY Cooking Channel and it'll cost you
under $20 we actually had a video hon
Josh we did how to make one how did you
invent this I didn't invent it I just
found it on the internet cuz my
brother's like bored and I'm like I'm
bored too so I'm like [ __ ] I didn't
bring my [ __ ]
I didn't bring my flashlight we do and
you guys shared what well you know arts
and crafts time but you just go to
Walmart you can get all this [ __ ] there
it'll cost you under 20 the cashiers
gonna know I was self-conscious about
that actually rubber gloves so yeah you
would need sponges to each latex gloves
rubber bands latex gloves and a Pringles
can and some trash bags to put in there
and that's it oh and then best week Oh
surprisingly it feels pretty damn good
really yeah like I would rather do that
than use put like because I used to do
it with just putting Vaseline on my hand
why would you do such a thing
we'll put vaseline on my hand yeah
doesn't it slip no I
I thought everyone you did someone on my
side I tried with lotion yeah but it's
too watery yeah my tooth I just like the
firm grip of my own hand
so you're dry the only time I like that
is if you go dry and a little bit of
pre-cum pops up and you could use that
as lubrication
but you know what I'm uncircumcised okay
that's wrong there's protection yeah see
that's why I rather do that dry Dan yeah
how'd you spit if you spit no I don't
need to because the whole the skin is
covered the whole way you're right it
feels good just do it yeah I'm my own
flashlight must feel fantastic that's
why it's for me it's it's it's swim in
my hand and then fleshlight [ __ ] you
know I tried
I even tried just sandwiching the
[ __ ] couch thing and [ __ ] back
yeah I tried a lot of things sex must be
amazing for you it's very different in
well yeah let's let's talk about that
how he's ashamed of my elephant trunk
yeah hell of shame I even begged my dad
I was like in fourth grade like dad I
compared my dicks with all my friends
there's something wrong and there's
something different they told me I'm not
circumcised and they laugh please I need
to get circumcised he goes no God major
this way there's no reason to cut that
tip off and then later I find out that
like Christians and Jewish they do but
then years later right I started reading
this research there's a movement with
guys trying to uncircumcised their skin
back or something worldstar dude long
story short I get I I have more nerve
endings yeah yeah it looks like a
choking turtle that's okay it's okay
visualize your dick no it's not just
mine if it's all uncircumcised penises
of the world it's all of Europe yeah all
right so about this story like nine
minutes in okay 3,000 incoming freshmen
at the Rochester Institute of Technology
attended their freshman orientation
seminar and during that freshman
orientation there was a presentation on
preventing sexual assault called alcohol
and chill and that's when the students
were introduced to this acronym called
group so it's rub one out holy [ __ ]
apparently my college revamp their
freshman orientation to teach about how
to not rape I just
holy [ __ ] and then my hair you can see
in this uh
it's in his mom's name is kanga okay
okay one out so then right here it says
self-gratification can prevent sexual
assaults oh wow they just solved all
rape and assault case that's stupid dumb
school thing taken out of context really
they are promoting to rub one out but
apparently it was part of the entire
presentation like they did apologize
because they're students saying that
they felt personally offended like
specially students that have
some sort of like sexual assault because
they're saying like now they're just
making light of it and now it's like a
meme in the school everyone just makes
fun of it and they don't really take the
whole message serious and so the school
was just apologizing saying that they
were gonna be more sensitive in the
future programs but they still stand by
that accurate acronym hold on guys I'm
gonna go rue myself this is the best way
to teach nor rape okay I believe in the
hole for a whole system so you go if a
girl says no and you enter her Hall then
when you get caught a big man will enter
your hole
I'm down for that yeah I'm down for that
dude I don't like that I want to use
that Turner I'm gonna rule myself you
don't need to go jail nah there's just a
bunch of volunteers that are horny in
forces they want to [ __ ] your butthole
and you entered the girl when she said
no he will enter you when you say no
that's all hello everybody
if you liked the video make sure that
you guys leave us a thumbs up because if
not I'm gonna find you where you live
and I'm gonna hug the [ __ ] out of you
with you other than that you know
there's like more videos up there bro
[Music]